the talk has found their man literally
jerry o'connell
jerry what does it feel like to be the
first man onto the show
um it does feel a little groundbreaking
i guess
it's groundbreaking for sure it um it
does feel groundbreaking but at the same
time
the ladies here i mean cheryl amanda
elaine
they're so they were so welcoming i i i
came on temporarily the last few months
and
they're they're so nice you know i mean
everybody knows i i want tell me why you
couldn't say no to this gig
other than you and i working on the same
line we get to run into each other now
more regularly
why couldn't you say no to this kid um
because
i get to be near you that's right kevin
michelle
everyone there you go i think after this
like year and a half that we've all been
through
i wanted to have some fun i just wanted
to get
this is the first time i have not been
in underwear in my house in a year and a
half
but i just wanted to have a good time
and uh i think that's what we're gonna
do
on the uh on the old talk
the newest member on the top
[Applause]
other big news for you you're
celebrating 14 year anniversary yeah
hold on before we get there is there
anything off limits for tv
with the wife and the kids are they like
don't talk about this when you get on
the show jared
we my wife and i have two 12 year old
daughters
so i mean they just know everything and
with social media
they're like up on it all you know i
mean it's pretty crazy too because my
kids have social media now so they read
comments
and they're like dad like why did you
say that and
that's how they talk now talk to me
about the host you mentioned before it's
been a warm welcome
is there any hazing going on is there
any new guy hosting hazel you can share
with us tell me about there's a lot of
hazing stuff that happens when you come
here to the talk no there is no hazing
everyone's been really welcome you know
i mean
i think the only hazing that does happen
is um
being a new personality on a show
i think people are used to seeing other
people there and
i think it takes a little time for
people to get used to it you know i tend
to get excited
and sort of energetic and just based on
instagram comments sometimes that
annoys people so like don't read those
comments dude
i shouldn't but i do i read them all but
um what do you bring to this is that
what you bring to the show you got this
this like ball of energy and this
this different kind of comedy what what
do you bring specifically here
you know i don't know if i'd bring this
it was already there but what i think
i enhance at the talk is just
us having fun you know i mean if
somebody says or does something or we're
doing a story on something that
remotely makes me laugh or i think is
like funny or interesting
like we're gonna we're gonna hammer that
you know we're gonna
we're gonna go right in there it um i
think it's mostly about just us
breaking down the stories and having a
good time i knew that was coming out
having a good time while doing it i mean
i know that's like an adage that you
hear like hey man i'm just
we're just here to have a good time on
the talk but really it's um
it's time to have a good time yeah and
the funny thing is is
long before you had this great
opportunity at the talk
you were with e.t you you were our guest
correspondent in 1986. oh my gosh
i remember this i just got to see how
everything was put together
and yeah no i've always come here
i almost had it the thanksgiving day
parade is great but this year i thought
uh
one more time
this is jerry o'connell entertainment
tonight
that's crazy so based on this you need
to change nothing just keep being this
amazing guy
based on that i shouldn't have gotten
the job but that is so funny you can
hear i am from new york you can hear i
still had a little bit of a knee luck
accent there
um wow it's amazing my voice really has
changed since then
what'd you learn what'd you learn that
day that you can you can take to this
job
this is what i learned that day you can
mess up as much as you want
they'll still hire you don't worry if
you make a mistake it means nothing
um no i really i specifically remember
that and how much
what a fun day that was that was at the
thanksgiving day parade
the macy's thanksgiving day parade and
we sort of went behind the scenes and i
grew up in new york and had seen it
up until that point in my 12 year old
life every year
and it was i really think it was one of
like those first instances where like
wow i gotta be in showbiz because you
know i was always
behind the barriers at the parade
watching everything and then
entertainment tonight
gave me a pass and went no no come on in
we're gonna go past the barriers and i
was
at the parade and i remember thinking
like this showbiz
thing i still have that um that press
pass that
uh entertainment tonight got me um oh
it's amazing you have to instagram a
post of it if you find it
yeah i assured it was um it was so fun
everyone was so kind to me you know i
i never held a mic you can tell from my
my demo reel there yeah i like yeah
luckily the people that talk
luckily the bosses here didn't see that
uh and say
we gotta get that guy you know you're
also celebrating
next month the 35th anniversary of stand
by me
crazy crazy because it doesn't it feels
like yesterday to me that movie was a
big part
you weren't of my very nice matthew but
i don't think you were alive when that
thing came out yeah i i
yeah right what do you remember take me
back give me a good memory of that time
in your life
you know the movie's about um
four childhood friends who go off on an
adventure
and you know they
never had friends like they did when
they were 12 and um
the four of us shooting that summer we
shot it in oregon
i'll never have friends like that again
you know i'm so fortunate
to have had that experience but to also
have a movie
that captures that experience you know i
just think it's one of those
coming-of-age films
that i think kids and adults really can
share and now it's one of those films
that like
adults show their kids now and it's just
sort of a mutual
sharing emotional experience
so it's one of the few times i can get
my kids to sit down and watch a movie
from my past and like i tried to show
them
you know like movies that really moved
me when i was younger like
rambo yeah and my daughters just weren't
into it
and i was like this is a classic this is
rambo yeah
and they weren't into it um i don't see
what they wouldn't like about it i tried
to show them uh
patrick swayze god rest his soul i tried
to show them road house
classic film sam elliott and my kids
weren't into it and i was like
you have to watch this this is classic
cinema um
and they were like we don't want to
watch this dad we're on tick tock
um but stand by me is one of those
movies that they really sat down and
watched you know
yeah it's a good one it links us all
together yeah jerry congratulations man
welcome to this video it's so nice you
guys are all so kind i mean
not only you know you but everybody
here in the cbs paramount plus
family and um and we're gonna have some
fun everybody
[Music]
you